This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
这是一档心心相印播客节目。保证全由真人录制。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难抉择》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯。这个节目旨在探讨黑人男性的生活经历，进行一些在其他地方真的无法坦诚交流的对话，但在这里，你是在和一位知晓如何处理这一切的持牌专业人士进行交流。
How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones.
有多少男人穿着西装或盔甲？这向世界传达了一个信号：你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去使用它。请在AHA广播应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难抉择》。2023年，2%的《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你对这个特定的检测进行了两次篡改，对某人，对吗？我篡改了一次检测。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出了一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern. and worry. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier,
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困之爱》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们在奇怪的现代生活中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。和担忧。经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
更充实、更健康的人。请在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他不会得逞的。他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。收听《闺蜜们。相信我，宝贝》，在Iheart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，这是一档播客节目，在这里我们探讨二十岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。
everybody, welcome back to the show, welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here for another episode. Today, we're going to discuss something that I think happens quite a bit in our 20s, but never really receives the same acknowledgement or attention that it deserves. We hear a lot about breakups about romantic relationships that end. But what about our platonic relationships? What about our friendships? What I really want to explore today is that experience of outgrowing your friends, of outgrowing relationships and why it's really natural and really normal and maybe even a step beyond that, even beneficial in some ways to find that your childhood, high school or university,
大家好，欢迎回到节目，欢迎回到本期播客，新听友们，老听友们，无论你们身处世界的哪个角落。非常高兴大家能来收听又一期节目。今天，我们要讨论一件我认为在我们二十岁时经常发生，却从未真正受到应有承认或关注的事情。我们听过很多关于分手、关于浪漫关系结束的话题。但是我们的柏拉图式关系呢？我们的友情呢？我今天真正想探讨的是那种超越朋友、超越关系的感觉，以及为什么发现你的童年、高中或大学时期的
best friends are no longer the same people, you're no longer the same person, and noticing when it is time to move on and dealing with that experience. I think that our idea of friendship growing up and in our late teens, even early 20s, is often quite unrealistic and highly romanticized. We see friendships, unlike our romantic relationships, as these everlasting relationships that are only disrupted by huge falling outs or massive events that either last forever or come to an end in an instant. But as we enter our 20s, we can see that friendships are a lot more nuanced and not always black and white. Like any relationship, they can be emotionally complex and confusing, but drifting away from a friend isn't a bad thing. It's actually an entirely natural part of growing up
挚友不再是同一个人，你也不再是同一个人，这其实是非常自然、非常正常的事情，甚至在某种程度上可以说是超越了这一步，甚至是有益的，并注意到什么时候该向前迈进并应对这种体验。我认为，我们在成长过程中以及在十几岁后期、甚至二十岁出头时对友谊的看法往往相当不切实际，并且高度浪漫化。我们把友谊看作是那种永恒的关系，这与我们的恋爱关系不同，它们只会被巨大的决裂或重大事件所打扰，要么永远持续下去，要么瞬间结束。但当我们进入二十岁时，我们可以看到友谊要微妙得多，并不总是非黑即白。像任何关系一样，它们在情感上可能很复杂、令人困惑，但与朋友渐行渐远并不是一件坏事。这实际上是成长过程中完全自然的一部分，
and growing into yourself. You don't have to feel ashamed or like you owe anyone an explanation. It's actually fairly common and I really want to normalize this experience. I think another lesson we are bound to learn in our 20s is that when it comes to friendships, quality over quantity is always the way. I think when I was in my early years of university, I had this tendency and need to be friends with everyone I met and maintain those relationships, even when we both realized we were incompatible.
也是成长为真正的自己的一部分。你不必感到羞耻，也不必觉得你欠任何人一个解释。这其实相当普遍，我真的很想让这种体验变得正常化。我认为我们在二十岁时必将学到的另一课是，在友谊方面，质量永远重于数量。我想在我大学刚开始的那几年里，我有这样一种倾向和需求，那就是想和遇到的每一个人都做朋友，并维持这些关系，即使我们双方都意识到我们并不合拍。
It was exhausting to try and have these special moments, steep conversations, and vulnerability with everyone, even people who I knew would probably never get me. But when I began to unpack the root cause of that habit that really I was just terrified of being alone and not constantly being surrounded by people, I was able, I think, to become a lot more selective and really pour my love and appreciation and time into the people and into the friendships that meant the most to me. The result of this was kind of a period of about 12 months or so where I found that my social circle just slowly began to shrink and I naturally drifted away from a lot of these people that I was trying so hard to stay friends with and that was really
试图与每个人——甚至是我知道可能永远不会理解我的人——拥有这些特殊的时刻、深度的对话和脆弱感，这太令人筋疲力尽了。但当我开始剖析那个习惯的根本原因时，发现我其实只是害怕孤独，害怕不被人群时刻包围，我想我能够变得更有选择性，真正把我的爱、感激和时间倾注在那些对我最重要的人和友谊上。其结果大约是持续了12个月左右的一个时期，我发现我的社交圈开始慢慢缩小，我自然而然地与许多我曾拼命维持朋友关系的人渐行渐远，而这真的很
scary. I felt like I'd abandoned these friends and they'd abandoned me but as well as you know as time goes on, I think it gives us the hindsight and the wisdom to realize that sometimes friendships need to fizzle and end for you to find new versions of yourself and for you to find new people who will match your energy and your identity. So today I want to break down why we outgrow our friendships, especially during this decade of huge personal growth and transformation, when we can recognize that a friendship is perhaps feeling a little bit stale or unfulfilling, the research, the psychology behind this that concludes that this is actually a healthy experience, and one that we should come to value and accept,
可怕。我觉得我抛弃了这些朋友，他们也抛弃了我，但随着时间的推移，我认为它给了我们后见之明的智慧，让我们意识到有时友谊需要消亡和结束，这样你才能找到新版本的自己，找到能够配合你的能量和认同感的新人。所以今天我想剖析一下，为什么我们会在友谊中渐渐疏远，尤其是在这个个人大幅成长和转变的十年里，当我们意识到一段友谊可能开始变得有点乏味或无法满足需求时，这背后的研究和心理学结论表明，这其实是一种健康的体验，一种我们应该学会重视和接受的体验，
but also discussing some of those harder parts of this experience. You know, how to end things in a good place, how to process sometimes even the grief for what used to be, And finally, the value of solitude and how to feel comfortable with being alone as we outgrow certain people in our 20s. I think there's a pretty general fear that as we age, we're going to become more isolated and these large networks will disappear. So what we do is we maintain relationships with people out of habit and out of fear, even when we know that we've outgrown each other. Firstly, I don't think that that's necessarily accurate that, you know, we'll never
但同时也要讨论这种体验中一些比较艰难的部分。你知道，如何好聚好散，如何去消化有时甚至是对过去的怀念所带来的悲伤，最后，探讨独处的价值，以及在我们二十岁超越某些人时，如何对孤独感到舒适。我认为人们普遍有一种恐惧，那就是随着我们年龄的增长，我们会变得更加孤立，这些庞大的社交网络将会消失。所以我们所做的是，出于习惯和恐惧，继续维持与人们的关系，即使我们知道我们已经超越了彼此。首先，我不认为这种看法一定准确，即我们永远不会
have more friends than we have in our 20s, but that fear also highlights an important skill that we need to prioritize during this decade, which is the ability to enjoy time spent alone and in our own company and learn to walk away from the relationships that don't serve us and let other people do the same. So let's get into it and discuss the new. nuances and explanations behind why we outgrow our friendships. I think it goes without saying that friendships are some of the most valuable relationships that we will experience in life. And good friends, they are even more valuable.
拥有比二十岁时更多的朋友，但这种恐惧也突显了我们在这一十年中需要优先培养的一项重要技能，那就是享受独处时光和陪伴自己的能力，并学会离开那些不再适合我们的关系，让其他人也这样做。让我们深入探讨一下，讨论我们超越友谊的新细微差别和解释。不言而喻，友谊是我们在生活中经历的最有价值的关系之一。而好朋友则更加珍贵。
They improve our mental and physical health. You know, a 2017 study found that close friendships are a huge predictor of improved mental health, cognitive functioning, and even reduced anxiety and stress levels. You know, friendship literally has a psychological capacity to change our bodies and to change our brains for the better. But friendship is not always black and white, and it's very natural to find that the older we get, the more of our friendships we tend to outgrow. There are many reasons why we find that a friendship that used to be the perfect fit, full of special moments and compatibility has suddenly changed and it's no longer right for us in our current
他们改善了我们的身心健康。你知道，2017年的一项研究发现，亲密的友谊是改善心理健康、认知功能甚至降低焦虑和压力水平的重要预测指标。你知道，友谊字面上面具有改变我们的身体和大脑向更好方向发展的心理能力。但友谊并不总是非黑即白，随着年龄的增长，我们往往会发现越来越多的友谊被我们超越，这是非常自然的。有很多原因让我们发现，一段曾经是完美契合、充满特别时刻和契合度的友谊已经突然改变，它不再适合我们当前的生活
period of life. Often it's a slow realization brought on by distance or change in circumstances where we gradually come to realize that what once was is no longer and we may be holding on just for the sake of nostalgia or even the expectation that it will somehow go back to the way it was. But the thing that makes outgrowing friendships so natural and normal is that it aligns with those changes and moments where we are outgrowing old versions of ourselves. And with that, the relationships that were part of that former identity. As we grow up, as we age, we will inevitably shift and change. We will take on new hobbies and attitudes, beliefs, jobs. We will experience significant life transitions, meet new people, all of these things and more.
阶段。通常这是一种由距离或环境变化带来的缓慢认识，我们逐渐意识到曾经的一切已不复存在，我们可能只是为了怀旧，或者甚至是出于某种期望它能以某种方式回到过去的愿望而苦苦支撑。但让超越友谊变得如此自然和正常的原因是，它与我们超越旧版本自己的那些变化和时刻相吻合。随之而来的，是作为旧身份一部分的关系。当我们长大，随着年龄的增长，我们不可避免地会发生转变和改变。我们将承担新的爱好、态度、信仰、工作。我们将经历重大的生活转变，结识新的人，所有这些以及更多。
And that person you were five years ago, part of that person no longer exists or it's been replaced by something newer and more aligned with who you are in this moment, in this time. I think that's one of the things that keeps life from being boring is knowing that we are constantly shifting into a deeper, different, but hopefully more mature, version of ourselves and that we can reinvent ourselves and try new things at any time, especially in our 20s when this is not only permissible but highly encouraged by our society. Whilst we're on this journey, the people in our life are going through the exact same process and they are changing in their own way and in their own direction. And sometimes those changes are not occurring in
而五年前的那个你，那部分自我已经不复存在，或者已经被更新、更符合此时此刻的你的东西所取代。我认为，这是让生活免于枯燥的事情之一，那就是知道我们不断地转变为一个更深刻、不同但希望更成熟的自己，而且我们可以在任何时候重塑自己并尝试新事物，特别是在二十岁的时候，这不仅是被允许的，而且深受我们社会的强烈鼓励。在我们踏上这段旅程的同时，我们生命中的人也在经历着完全相同的过程，他们正以自己的方式和方向在改变。有时这些变化并不是
parallel, which leads to a distance forming in our friendships, especially when the things that you once bonded over and shared like your uni course or workplace or sports team that you played for, they're no longer strong enough to bring you together and to create those shared experiences and closeness that is the pillar of every friendship. That's part of life, sad and painful as it may be. and even if you find that your relationship and that your friendship with someone isn't necessarily over, it may have faded a bit and lost some of that deepness and connection you formerly had. And that it's okay, it's a sign of growth, a sign of development, the sign of a new chapter for both of you. There are some crucial things that can really alter the course of a friendship,
平行的，这导致我们的友谊中产生了距离，尤其是当你们曾经因之建立联系和分享的事物，比如你们的大学课程、工作场所或你们曾效力的运动队，不再足够强大，无法将你们凝聚在一起，无法创造出作为每段友谊基石的那些共同经历和亲密感时。这就是生活的一部分，尽管它可能既悲伤又痛苦；即使你发现你与某人的关系和友谊不一定结束了，它可能已经有些褪色，失去了你们以前拥有的那种深度和联系。但这没关系，这是成长的一个标志，是发展的标志，是你们两人翻开新篇章的标志。有些关键事情真的可以改变友谊的轨迹，
most of which are linked to those lifestyle and value changes we were speaking to earlier. The first big one that I've noticed, maybe you've noticed this as well, is distance. Something that becomes so much more commonplace, the deeper we get into our 20s, is that people move away from the places where you once met and settled. So a friend made this observation to me the other day, and I thought it was brilliant, that a sign of adulthood is having friends in multiple cities across the world, because after we graduate high school and then uni, people are inevitably going to scatter across every country, across the world, and you can no longer kind of, you know, pop into their house down the street anymore or
其中大部分与我们之前谈到的生活方式和价值观的变化有关。我注意到的第一个重大变化，也许你也注意到了，那就是距离。随着我们更深入地进入二十岁，变得越来越普遍的一件事是，人们会搬离你们曾经相遇和定居的地方。所以前几天一个朋友向我观察到了这一点，我觉得这太精彩了：成年的一個标志就是在世界各地的多个城市拥有朋友，因为在我们高中毕业然后大学毕业后，人们不可避免地会散落到世界各地的每一个国家，你再也不能像以前那样，突然造访他们街头那栋房子，或者
see them in class. And that distance, it changes dynamics because closeness and familiarity are the core pillar of friendship. And those things are often supported by things like physical proximity and convenience. It becomes harder to be part of each other's daily lives, daily routines, daily conversations, and you're obviously bound to grow apart a little bit. This doesn't necessarily mean that you need to call time of death on the friendship. Some of my best friends, my closest friends, are people who I rarely see in person. You know, we all went to uni together in Canberra and then one by one they've moved on to, you know, Melbourne, Tasmania, London, Darwin, all over the place.
在课堂上见到他们了。这种距离改变了动态，因为亲密感和熟悉感是友谊的核心支柱。而这些东西通常是由物理上的接近和便利等因素支持的。要成为彼此日常生活、日常例行公事、日常对话的一部分变得更加困难，你们显然注定会稍微疏远一些。这并不一定意味着你需要给这段友谊判处死刑。我的一些挚友，最亲密的朋友，是我很少亲自见到的人。你知道，我们都在堪培拉一起上过大学，然后他们一个接一个地搬到了墨尔本、塔斯马尼亚、伦敦、达尔文，到处都是。
But the friendships have survived and continued to flourish because we still share so many of the same values and have that unconditional love and support for each other and really enjoy the time that we do spend with each other. It's not necessarily just distance that causes you to grow apart but other more nuanced factors. One of those is the entrance of serious romantic partners. When we're single, our friendships are our primary relationship, the person we go to for everything, who we share all the good and bad of our life with, and in a decade of instability and often a desired, you know, separation from our parents and families, we move away from our hometowns, we are really trying to separate our child identity and build an adult identity.
但这些友谊得以幸存并继续蓬勃发展，是因为我们仍然分享着许多相同的价值观，对彼此有着无条件的爱与支持，并且真正享受我们在一起度过的时光。不一定仅仅是距离导致你们疏远，还有其他更微妙的因素。其中之一就是认真的恋爱伴侣的出现。当我们单身时，友谊是我们最重要的关系，是我们遇到什么事都会去找的人，是我们分享生活中所有美好与糟糕时刻的人。在一个动荡不安的十年里，我们经常渴望脱离父母和家庭，搬离我们的家乡，我们真正试图剥离儿童的身份并建立成人身份。
Our friends become family, those are the ones that we are closest to. but when we begin dating people, especially more seriously, you make a trade-off with spending time with your friends to spend time with your partner because, you know, you're probably obsessed with each other, you're getting to know everything about them, you're wanting to spend every day in their presence, and that's not a bad thing, and it's not as if you've abandoned your friends, at least not in most instances. it's just that we only have a number of hours in our weeks and in our days, and the entrance of a new primary relationship is going to take up more of that time and more of that time that we previously reserved for friends.
我们的朋友变成了家人，他们是我们最亲近的人。但当我们开始与人约会，尤其是更认真地约会时，你会用陪伴朋友的时间来换取陪伴伴侣的时间，因为，你知道，你们可能彼此痴迷，你们在了解关于对方的一切，你们希望每天都出现在对方身边，这并不是一件坏事，这也不是说你抛弃了朋友，至少在大多数情况下不是这样。只是我们的周和天里只有有限的小时数，而一段新的核心关系的出现将占用更多的时间，占用那些我们以前留给朋友的时间。
I have friends who are absolutely amazing, are balancing their romantic partners and their friendships, but no matter what, the dynamic is going to shift, and with that, sometimes that closeness is also lost. It doesn't mean that they're a shitty friends, or that you're a shitty friend. It's just how life goes as we get older and begin having more serious relationships. You know, we all know what it's like to lose a friend to a partner.
我有一些绝对棒极了的朋友，他们在浪漫伴侣和友谊之间取得了平衡，但无论如何，动态都会发生变化，随之而来的是，有时那种亲密感也会丧失。这并不意味着他们是糟糕的朋友，或者你是个糟糕的朋友。这只是随着我们长大并开始拥有更认真的关系，生活顺其自然的发展方式。你知道，我们都知道因伴侣而失去一个朋友是什么滋味。
And it probably won't be the last time. And it's not something that they need to be shamed for or need to be, you know, made to feel bad for. It's just part of growing up. It's part of enjoying a new period and chapter of life. This links really perfectly with the other major factor. and life change that we observe, which is that our priorities begin to differ. And with that, our values, our attitudes, and what we enjoy doing. Like I mentioned before, psychology explains that we often become bonded with people
而且这可能不会是最后一次。这也不是一件需要让他们感到羞耻或让他们（你知道的）感到糟糕的事情。这只是长大的一部分。这是享受生活新阶段和新篇章的一部分。这与我们观察到的另一个主要因素和生活变化完美契合，那就是我们的优先事项开始变得不同。随之而来的是我们的价值观、态度以及我们喜欢做的事情。正如我之前提到的，心理学解释说，我们经常通过相似的共同经历与人建立联系。这些经历创造了一个双方都可以汲取的共同叙事。
through similar shared experiences. These experiences, they create a shared narrative that both people can tap into. and it also imitates similarity and interpersonal compatibility because they've been through or are currently experiencing the same things that you are. And from that, you have conversation topics, you have people that you mutually know, perhaps gossip that you can share, priorities that are aligned, and that is normally the foundation for your relationship. The example that I always think of is the difference in the dynamic of our friendships in our very early 20s versus our late 20s, mainly due to factors like context.
它还模拟了相似性和人际兼容性，因为他们经历过或正在经历与你相同的事情。从那以后，你有了对话话题，有了你们共同认识的人，也许是可以分享的八卦，相一致的优先事项，而这通常是你们关系的基石。我总是想到的一个例子是我们二十岁出头与二十岁晚期友谊动态的区别，主要由于诸如语境之类的因素。
When I was in my early days at uni, I am not proud to say it, but my days were consumed by partying until 2 a.m., waking up at 11, studying super hard, hanging out with the same people, doing stupid things, and then partying again. You know, rinse and repeat. And most of us were in the same boat. We had just moved out of home, we had this incredible freedom, but also this common purpose to study, to get good grades and to graduate.
当我在大学刚开始的时候，我很不好意思地说，我的日子就是在派对中度过直到凌晨2点，11点醒来，超级努力地学习，和同一群人闲逛，做蠢事，然后再去派对。你知道，不断重复。我们大多数人都处于同一条船上。我们刚搬出家门，我们拥有这种不可思议的自由，但也有着共同的目标，那就是学习、取得好成绩并毕业。
That discrete period of time brought us closer because we were going through the same thing and we had the same priority. But now, a lot of us have jobs. We can't afford the time and energy to party the same way we did, to drink the way we did. But we also have a lot less free time because most of us have structures. lives with nine to five jobs and chores and obligations and partners. And we also have a different priority. You know, we've graduated. We've moved on. However, there are some people I know who didn't give up that lifestyle or they're still studying whilst, you know, I'm out here working my corporate job and only drinking on weekends. That's fine. It's just that our priorities are no
那段特定时间让我们更加亲密，因为我们经历着同样的事情，有着相同的优先事项。但现在，我们许多人都有了工作。我们无法承担像以前那样去派对、像以前那样喝酒的时间和精力。但我们也拥有少得多的空闲时间，因为我们大多数人都有着结构化的生活，有着朝九晚五的工作、杂务、义务和伴侣。而且我们也有了不同的优先事项。你知道，我们毕业了。我们继续前进了。然而，我认识的一些人并没有放弃那种生活方式，或者他们还在学习，而（你知道）我在外面做着我的公司工作，只在周末喝酒。这没关系。只是我们的优先事项不再
longer aligned. And further to that, those lessons that we all kind of had, we've taken away different things from those lessons. We've taken away different lessons from those experiences, and that's created different values, different attitudes, expectations. And with that, a diverging identity that is no longer singularly centered on our identity as, you know, chaotic university students with the same kind of. priorities. That is a natural part of growing up. It's not something that is anyone's fault. You cannot remain stagnant your whole life just because you're not willing to outgrow people. And it seems like a hard trade-off. But there are, you know, it also does come a point where we can't help but change.
一致了。除此之外，我们从那些经验中都有所收获，我们从这些经历中汲取了不同的教训，这创造了不同的价值观、不同的态度和期望。随之而来的是一种分化的身份，不再单纯地以我们作为（你知道的）有着相同优先事项的混乱大学生的身份为中心。这是长大成人自然的一部分。这不是任何人的错。你不能因为不愿意超越别人而一辈子停滞不前。这似乎是一个艰难的权衡。但也有（你知道的）这样一个时刻，我们情不自禁地改变。
And with that, the dynamics of our relationships, of our friendships are going to change as well. you may also have friends who have had kids super early or they have decided to travel the world whilst you've taken maybe a more slow or scenic route and what you may find as a result is that each week each month it gets a little bit harder to find things to talk about a little bit harder to keep in touch with all that's going on in both of your lives and one day you realize you know you really don't know each other anymore. And in that moment, you don't need to artificially try and reignite that friendship. Sometimes it's just best to let life run its course, to cherish the memories, and move on. You never know when they're going to come back into your life. You never know if it's going to be
随之而来的是，我们关系、我们友谊的动态也会发生变化。你可能还会有一些朋友，他们超早地生了孩子，或者他们决定环游世界，而你可能采取了一条更慢或风景更美的路线，因此你可能会发现，每周、每个月，要找到共同话题变得越来越困难，要跟上彼此生活中发生的一切变得越来越困难，有一天你意识到（你知道）你们真的再也不了解对方了。在那一刻，你不需要刻意去重新点燃那段友谊。有时最好让生活顺其自然，珍惜回忆，然后继续前进。你永远不知道他们什么时候会回到你的生活中。你永远不知道它是否会
naturally rekindled and you'll find that your paths cross again. There's a saying that I love, and it's that people are in your life for a season, a reason, or a lifetime. That phrase is so comforting to me. But sometimes we put people into the wrong category and they put us into the wrong category as well. You think it's forever that your soulmates and forever bonded and then one of you moves or gets married or decides to travel the world and all these things bring new experiences that you just can't relate to anymore
自然地重燃，你会发现你们的道路再次交汇。我有一句很喜欢的名言，那就是人们出现在你的生活里，或是一季，或是一个理由，或是一生。这句话对我来说是如此的抚慰人心。但有时我们把人放错了类别，他们也把我们放错了类别。你以为那是永远的，你们是灵魂伴侣，永远绑定在一起，然后你们中的一个人搬家了，或者结婚了，或者决定去环游世界，所有这些事情都带来了你再也无法感同身受的新体验，
and you realize that it was just for a season, it was just for a reason, not for a lifetime. And I think all of these previous events or experiences, they relate to what I call the fizzle. It's kind of like a slow burnout of the relationship rather than a relationship breakup, which is often, you know, violent and a traumatic departure of a friend from our lives due to a big falling out, miscommunication or just all outghosting. So I want to kind of explain that difference a little bit more. The difference between a fizzle and, you know, when you really need to be like, okay, this relationship, has turned sour, it's turned a little bit toxic, we should probably cut each other off. I think that's
然后你意识到那只是一季，只为了一个理由，而不是一生。我想所有这些先前的事件或经历，都与我所说的“消亡”有关。这有点像关系的缓慢燃尽，而不是关系的分手，那通常是（你知道的）激烈的，由于巨大的决裂、沟通不畅或彻底的失联，朋友从我们生活中痛苦的离开。所以我想多解释一下这种区别。“消亡”和（你知道的）当你真正需要表现得像“好吧，这段关系已经变质了，变得有点毒了，我们大概应该互相断交了”时的区别。我认为那是
different to signs that you're drifting, and it's important to recognize when it might be time to just be honest with yourself about whether that person is a seasoned friend or a reason friend. In my own experiences, these are some of the biggest indicators that a friendship is kind of moving more towards a casual relationship or an acquaintance. Firstly, your friendship is rooted in the past. all you talk about are things that have already happened, either from a place of nostalgia or bitterness. You know, if you're unable to move on from talking about certain friends or partners or people who have hurt you or your high school days or recounting the same events over and over again, maybe it's time to realize that your friendship has somewhat lost its spark. Our minds should always be turned to the future. At least that's what I believe. So if you find that you always regress to a previous version of yourself when you're in the presence of someone,
不同的，它标志着你正在渐行渐远，重要的是要认识到什么时候可能是时候对自己诚实，弄清楚那个人到底是“一季朋友”还是“理由朋友”。在我自己的经历中，这些是一个友谊正在向泛泛之交或熟人转变的最大指标。首先，你们的友谊扎根于过去。你们谈论的全是已经发生的事情，要么带着怀旧，要么带着苦涩。你知道，如果你无法不再谈论某些朋友、伴侣、曾经伤害过你的人、你的高中时代，或者一遍又一遍地讲述相同的事件，也许是时候意识到你的友谊已经有些失去火花了。我们的思想应该永远面向未来。至少我是这么认为的。所以如果你发现在某个人的陪伴下，你总是退回到以前版本的自己，
it may indicate that the relationship isn't growing at the same pace as you are. Secondly, you find that you don't have much in common anymore. You struggle to find things to talk about. You feel nervous when you make plans with them because you're worried that it will be awkward. Maybe even you plan a list of conversation topics. I've done that before for sure. You just don't have anything in common. That's entirely normal.
这可能表明这段关系并没有和你以相同的速度成长。其次，你发现你们不再有太多共同点。你很难找到话题。当你和他们制定计划时，你会感到紧张，因为你担心会很尴尬。也许你甚至会列出一张对话话题清单。我以前肯定做过那种事。你们就是没有任何共同点。这完全是正常的。
We are not frozen in time at the time that we met someone. And our life paths are bound to diverge. Not always, of course, but when you start to find that you really can't talk the way you used to, that you no longer have those shared experiences and values, maybe it's just best to let both of you move on. The next indicator is a huge one, and I think it's for one that we can all relate to, it's when you no longer feel energized or excited around them or excited to see them. Friendship should leave us feeling excited by life. They should leave us feeling seen and
我们并不是在结识某人的那一刻被时间冻结的。我们的人生轨迹注定会分叉。当然并非总是如此，但当你开始发现你们真的无法像过去那样交谈，你们不再拥有那些共同的经历和价值观时，也许最好还是让双方都继续前进。下一个指标是一个巨大的指标，我认为这是我们所有人都能感同身受的一个，那就是当你不再从他们身边感到精力充沛或兴奋，或者不再为见到他们而感到兴奋时。友谊应该让我们对生活感到兴奋。它们应该让我们感到被看见、
confident and above all else energized and enthused. That's a non-negotiable. That is a complete non-negotiable for me. Yes, there are going to be times when one of you may be struggling. It might not be as exciting as you would like. You're offering more and emotional support, that's okay. But, you know, the status quo should always be that you feel better leaving an interaction with a friend than before you saw them. But if you're finding that you're leaving a situation feeling really drained, maybe even feeling worse about yourself, that's obviously not a great sign. But it is a sign of something, and that is that you might be outgrowing one another. The final indicator, I guess, is that the friendship has become one-sided.
自信，最重要的是充满精力和热情。那是一个没有商量余地的条件。这对我来说是完全没有商量余地的。是的，有时你们中可能会有人陷入困境。它可能不像你希望的那样令人兴奋。你提供更多的情感支持，那没关系。但是，（你知道的）现状应该始终是，离开与朋友的互动后，你感觉比见他们之前更好。但如果你发现你离开一个情况时感到精疲力竭，甚至对自己感觉更糟，那显然不是一个好兆头。但这是一个信号，那就是你们可能正在超越彼此。最后一个指标，我想，就是友谊变得有些单向了。
This may not be a sign that you are outgrowing a friend, but maybe that they are outgrowing you. That feeling always sucks. It can be really painful, especially if you're not on the same page, but you don't want to maintain any relationship that is one-sided, or in which you have to beg someone for their attention and their time. Maybe you're finding that you're always the one making plans whilst they always reschedule, or it takes ages for them to get back to you. They never have time to see you. They always seem to prioritize their other friendships. It's a hard pill to swallow, but maybe at that stage, you're better off connecting with people who value you for who you are and where you are in life and what you can bring, rather than trying to dig deeper into a
这可能不是你在超越朋友的信号，而可能是他们在超越你的信号。那种感觉总是很糟糕。这可能真的很痛苦，尤其是如果你们不在同一页上，但你不想维持任何单方面的关系，或者在那种关系中你不得不乞求别人的注意和时间。也许你发现你总是那个做计划的人，而他们总是重新安排，或者他们回复你需要很长时间。他们从来没有时间见你。他们似乎总是把其他友谊放在首位。这是一个很难接受的事实，但也许在那个阶段，你最好与那些因为你是谁、你在生活中的位置以及你能带来什么而重视你的人建立联系，而不是试图去深入挖掘一段
friendship that's kind of gone stale or gone silent. I think that final experience can be really tough and I'm sorry if you're going through that. And, you know, moving on from friends, finding that your relationship has changed. It's not always a pleasant experience or one that comes naturally. So I really want to discuss what you do next, why this experience can be so hard and how to embrace your solitude, maybe even your loneliness, whilst you're in between chapters of your life and kind of see it as an opportunity to really reconnect with yourself. and maybe make better friends, maybe make friends with people who are more suited to you. All of that in just a second.
已经有些变质或沉默的友谊。我认为最后的这种经历可能真的很艰难，如果你正在经历这些，我很抱歉。而且，（你知道的）与朋友分道扬镳，发现你们的关系已经改变。这并不总是一次令人愉快的经历，也不是自然而然发生的。所以我真的很想讨论接下来该做什么，为什么这段经历会如此艰难，以及如何在生活的各个章节之间拥抱你的独处，甚至是你的孤独，同时把它看作是一个真正重新连接自我的机会。
Realisation that we are outgrowing friends is not always an enjoyable experience. I feel like I don't even need to say that. It can leave us feeling kind of lonely and also guilty as if we've done something wrong or abandoned someone. It's an emotionally complex realization. But you cannot possibly keep every friend you've ever had. Imagine if you were still best friends with everyone that you've met since childhood. You wouldn't have room for any new relationships. Sometimes losing one person makes room for someone who is better suited for you
并可能交到更好的朋友，也许能交到更适合你的朋友。所有这些，马上就来。意识到我们正在超越朋友并不总是一段愉快的经历。我觉得我甚至不需要说出来。它会让我们感到有些孤独，也会感到内疚，就像我们做错了什么或抛弃了某人一样。这是一种情感上复杂的认识。但你不可能留住你所拥有的每一个朋友。想象一下，如果你和你自童年以来遇到的每个人都还是好朋友。你就没有空间容纳任何新的关系了。有时失去一个人会为更适合你的人腾出空间，
and where you are at in your life right now. Psychology has a lot to say about the experience about growing someone and perhaps losing a close friend. a lot of the intense emotions, they derive from the closeness you once had and how our brain responds to this. And it's very similar to the grief process that follows a death because our relationships are very valuable and core parts of our identity. So their absence does bring emotional pain. Like I said, moving on from a friendship, it involves a similar grief cycle to, death because it comes with recognizing that your former friend is no longer part of your life.
以及适合你目前生活状态的人。心理学对超越某人以及可能失去亲密朋友的经历有很多要说的。许多强烈的情绪，它们源于你们曾经拥有的亲密感以及我们大脑对此的反应。这非常类似于亲人去世后的悲伤过程，因为我们的关系是我们身份中非常宝贵的核心部分。所以他们的缺席确实会带来情感上的痛苦。就像我说的，离开一段友谊，涉及到一个类似于死亡的悲伤循环，因为它伴随着认识到你的前朋友不再是你生活的一部分。
They can't be called on in an instant. They won't be there for those core moments and milestones in your life and that you're going to have to move on. When we see someone every day or regularly for a period of time, our neurons become wide around their presence. We enjoy their company and you know when we are having a hard day we call them something important happens they're our go-to these repeated experiences these repeated pleasant experiences they facilitate nerve growth and connections between our synapses which are the tiny kind of roads that create maps through our brain and these relationships become integrated into how our brain processes the world and responds to certain events or experiences. So when those relationships begin to fizzle, our brain cannot respond as it has
你不能瞬间召唤他们。他们不会在你生命中的那些核心时刻和里程碑中出现，你将不得不继续前进。当我们每天或定期与某人见面一段时间时，我们的神经元会围绕他们的存在而交织。我们享受他们的陪伴，（你知道的）当我们度过艰难的一天时，我们会打电话给他们，重要的事情发生了他们是我们的首选，这些重复的经历，这些重复的愉快经历促进了神经生长和突触之间的连接，突触是通过我们的大脑创建地图的微小道路，这些关系已经融入到我们大脑处理世界和应对特定事件或体验的方式中。所以当这些关系开始消亡时，我们的大脑无法像以前那样作出反应，
previously, and this causes that sense of confusion and that sense of hurt. As a result, we may find that outgrowing of friendship involves a similar five-stage process to grief. Firstly, there's denial. You know, you deny that everything is fine, that you've just misinterpreted some of the signs, that it's just growing pains, everything's all right. And then there's anger at yourself, at them. It may involve lashing out and frustration at that other person, especially if you feel abandoned or wounded by the experience. Next comes bargaining or attempts to reverse the process and bring you back together by trying to replicate that former closeness and artificially create reasons to hang out more and create inorganic shared experiences. It might also be things like,
这引起了那种困惑感和受伤感。因此，我们可能会发现超越友谊的过程类似于悲伤的五个阶段。首先，是否认。你知道，你否认一切都很好，你只是误解了一些迹象，这只是生长痛，一切都好。然后是对自己、对他们的愤怒。这可能涉及对另一个人的抨击和沮丧，特别是如果你觉得被这种经历抛弃或伤害的话。接下来是讨价还价，或者试图扭转这个过程，通过试图复制那种以前的亲密感，并人为地创造多聚会的理由和不自然的共同经历，来让你们重新聚在一起。这也可能是诸如，
oh, you know, if me and this person stay friends, I won't make any new friends, or I'll pray every day, or I'll be the nicest person ever. Like, I promise to be kind. I promise to always be there for them just as long as we're still in each other's lives. Of course, that really works, if not ever, if a friendship is truly on the way out. You know, I saw this quote the other day. that when the universe knows that you two shouldn't be together, that you shouldn't have a relationship, it will create circumstances and situations that will make that apparent to you until you realize. Obviously, like we've said, that's a hard pill to swallow. And realizing that may involve a sense of depression and isolation or even overwhelming sadness
噢，（你知道的）如果我和这个人保持朋友关系，我就不会交任何新朋友，或者我每天都会祈祷，或者我会成为最好的人。比如，我保证保持善良。我保证永远陪伴他们，只要我们还在彼此的生活中。当然，如果友谊真的走到了尽头，这种方法很少奏效，如果说曾经奏效过的话。你知道，我前几天看到过这样一句话：当宇宙知道你们两个不应该在一起，你们不应该拥有一段关系时，它会创造环境和情况，使之对你显而易见，直到你意识到为止。显然，正如我们所说，这是一个很难接受的事实。而意识到这一点可能涉及一种抑郁和孤立感，甚至是一种压倒性的悲伤，
because it feels like a loss, it is a loss. but sometimes that's just the way that life goes. You have to go through hard things to enter into a new chapter to see the other side. And after all that has passed, we arrive at a place of acceptance as you come to terms with reality and understand that life will go on. You will make new friends. You will find other fulfilling connections. From personal experience, I've seen how this process goes
因为它感觉像是一种损失，这确实是一种损失。但有时这就是生活的方式。你必须经历艰难的事情才能进入一个新的章节，去看到另一面。在这一切过去之后，我们来到了一个接受的地方，当你坦然面对现实并理解生活将继续时。你会结交新朋友。你会找到其他令人满意的联系。根据我个人的经验，我已经看到了这个过程是如何进行的，
and can definitely confirm that it is a real thing. Sometimes, especially with that anger, when we recognize things changing in our relationships, our first instinct can be to lash out and act from a place of rage, anger, or even abandonment. I know that can feel like our most natural response. We don't like feeling abandoned or unseen or rejected, especially by those close to us.
并且绝对可以证实这是一件真实存在的事。有时，特别是在那种伴随着愤怒的时刻，当我们认识到关系中的变化时，我们的第一反应可能是抨击并出于愤怒、生气甚至被抛弃的情绪行事。我知道这可能感觉是我们最自然的反应。我们不喜欢被抛弃、被忽视或被拒绝，尤其是被我们亲近的人拒绝。
But I would really implore you to take some time to step back and consider the situation rationally. Things like distance or significant life changes. They don't always have to mean the end of a friendship. Sometimes it just means change. Don't rush to completely cut someone off, you know, or don't rush to yell at them, to be angry at them. See if you can find a way forward. take time to adjust to you and your friends new circumstances. But if you realize that it's just not happening for either of you,
但我真的恳请你花点时间退后一步，理性地考虑一下这种情况。诸如距离或重大的生活变化。并不总是意味着友谊的结束。有时它只意味着改变。不要急于彻底切断与某人的联系，（你知道的）或者不要急于对他们大喊大叫，对他们生气。看看你是否能找到前进的方法。花时间适应你和朋友的新情况。但如果你意识到你们双方都没有发生这种情况，
that the growth you've both experienced has created too much of a divide, try and end things kindly from a place of love and from a place of grace, by acknowledging that things are different and still making time for them, even if you would like to, for when they do want to see you, even if it's less regularly, but also just letting life take its course without rage, without emotional outbursts, without anger. You never know if things will change and you'll come back together in the future if you just need some time apart, so you don't want to burn any bridges before you have to.
你们两个所经历的成长造成了太大的分歧，试着以一种仁慈的方式结束事情，怀着爱和优雅，承认事情已经不同了，仍然为他们腾出时间，即使你愿意，为了他们确实想见你的时候，即使频率没那么高，但也只是让生活顺其自然，没有狂怒，没有情绪爆发，没有愤怒。你永远不知道事情是否会改变，如果你只是需要一些时间分开，你将来会重新聚在一起，所以你不想在必须之前烧断任何桥梁。
And I think the other thing to do is treat your alone time, your solitude is sacred. I think I spoke about this earlier, but sometimes we can find that we learn a lot in our own company and that often comes after we realize that we've outgrown people in our life. Maybe we're holding on to those relationships because we don't want to be alone. I think we often have a tendency to fill empty space with social interaction, which can leave us feeling more drained and exhausted. But solitude gives us time to reflect. It gives us time to think about what we want.
我想另一件要做的事情是，把你的独处时间、你的孤独视为神圣的。我想我之前谈到过这个，但有时我们会发现我们在自己的陪伴中学到了很多，这通常发生在我们意识到我们已经超越了生活中的人之后。也许我们一直在坚持这些关系，因为我们不想孤单。我认为我们经常有一种倾向，用社交互动来填补空白，这可能会让我们感到更加筋疲力尽。但独处给了我们反思的时间。它给了我们思考我们想要什么的时间。
It can allow us to be more independent and autonomous, to love ourselves deeply. Treating yourself like your own best friend, it's life-changing. It's something I've been trying to practice more, and I found that it's opened me up to more opportunities and really made me love myself more and be more selective with the friends they choose to have.
它能让我们更加独立和自主，深深地爱自己。把自己当作你自己的最好朋友，这是改变人生的。这是我一直在努力练习的事情，我发现它为我打开了更多的机会，并真正让我更爱自己，在选择朋友时更有选择性。
If I want to go do something, if I want to go to a new restaurant, go to a movie, visit a beautiful lake, or do a beautiful hike, I can do it by myself and still have an amazing time. And it's made me value the time spent with friends, spent with good friends, even more. Take it slow and try to integrate more solitary activities into your daily routine or push yourself to go to things alone, to go outside your comfort zone,
如果我想去做点什么，如果我想去一家新餐厅、看一场电影、参观一个美丽的湖泊或者进行一次美丽的徒步旅行，我可以自己完成，依然能过得很开心。这让我更加珍惜和朋友、和好朋友在一起的时光。放慢节奏，试着在日常生活中融入更多独自进行的活动，或者督促自己独自去一些地方，走出自己的舒适区，
instead of calling on friends that, you know, you actually don't enjoy time with, that you know you don't have that connection with anymore. I think in those moments where we do force ourselves to do things that are scary and not convenient and especially to do things alone, life really surprises you and you'll see some amazing self-development and growth. Finally, I think it goes without saying, but one of the major benefits of outgrowing friends, as hard as it may be, is the opportunity it presents to meet some new amazing people. You haven't yet met all the people you will love in your life.
而不是去联系那些你其实并不享受和他们在一起、你知道彼此之间已经没有那种连接的朋友。我认为，在那些我们强迫自己去做一些可怕的、不方便的事情，尤其是独自做事情的时刻，生活真的会给你带来惊喜，你会看到自己惊人的自我发展和成长。最后，不言而喻的是，超越旧友谊的主要好处之一（尽管过程可能很艰难）是它为你提供了结识新的优秀之人的机会。你生命中所有你会爱的人，你还没有全部遇到。
There will be more souls that touch you deeply, more laughter, more bonding experiences, more adventures, more people out there who will connect deeply with you. So don't let your fear of loneliness hold you back from self-discovery and from moving on. It's so much more worthwhile to be alone for a while. and to make space for new relationships that are perhaps more fulfilling, than to hold on to friendships that no longer serve you. I think that's all we have time for today. Thank you so much for tuning in for this episode.
会有更多触动你心灵的灵魂、更多的欢笑、更多的情感联结、更多的冒险，还有更多会与你产生深厚连接的人在等着你。所以，不要让对孤独的恐惧阻碍你去进行自我发现和向前迈进。独自待上一段时间，为那些可能更充实的新关系腾出空间，这要比死抓着那些不再适合你的友谊有价值得多。我想我们今天的时间就到这里了。非常感谢大家收听本期节目。
I really enjoyed it. It's something I talk a lot about with my friends and even with my parents and people I know that outgrowing friendships is super normal. It doesn't need to come with shame. It doesn't need to come with blame. more stigma. It's just part of growing up and it's so interesting talking to my parents about this who have been through that experience, obviously they're a lot older, and really confirm that to me and be like, as long as you end things in a place of grace and in a place of love, you never know if someone's
我真的很喜欢它。这是我和朋友、甚至和父母以及认识的人经常讨论的话题，那就是超越友谊是超级正常的事情。它不需要伴随着羞耻。它不需要伴随着指责或污名化。这只是成长的一部分，和我的父母谈论这件事非常有意思，他们经历过那种经历（显然他们年纪大得多），这真的向我证实了这一点，并且让我觉得，只要你以优雅和爱的方式结束一段关系，你永远不知道某个人
going to, you know, show up in your life again and you can rekindle that relationship. So it's just a really interesting topic. I think it's something that's super, super natural and super normal. So I hope that if you are in a place right now where maybe you're lonely or you're feeling really down on yourself because you're at this point where you are outgrowing old friendships, that you have some grace and kindness towards yourself and are able to recognize that the only thing it will do is open up new opportunities to spend time alone and to meet new people. So thank you so much for listening. Thank you so much for tuning in. If you enjoyed this episode and you feel cool to do so, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now.
是否会在你的生活中再次出现，然后你们可以重燃那种关系。所以这真的是一个非常有趣的话题。我认为这是超级、超级自然且超级正常的事情。所以我希望，如果你现在正处于这样一个阶段：也许你感到孤独，或者因为你正处于超越旧友谊的节点而对自己感到非常沮丧，那么请对自己保持温和与善良，并能够认识到，它唯一能做的事情就是为你打开新的机会去享受独处时光以及结识新朋友。非常感谢你们的聆听。非常感谢大家的收听。如果你喜欢本期节目，并且愿意这样做，请随时在 Apple Podcasts、Spotify 或你现在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。
It really helps the show grow, helps it reach new audiences. Maybe share this episode with a friend who needs to hear this. And if you want to hear more about the show, you want firsthand updates, you want to know what's coming next, things like merch, upcoming guests. Please feel free to follow me at That Psychology Podcast on Instagram. it's a great place to connect. If you have episode suggestions, I also very much welcome them there.
这真的能帮助节目成长，帮助它触及新的受众。也许可以把这期节目分享给一个需要听到这些话的朋友。如果你想了解更多关于节目的信息，想要第一手更新，想知道接下来会有什么内容，比如周边商品、即将做客的嘉宾。请随时在 Instagram 上关注我 @That Psychology Podcast，这是一个很好的交流地方。如果你有节目建议，我也非常欢迎你在那里提出。
So thank you so much for your time today. Thank you for listening. Thank you for tuning in. And I will be back next week with another episode. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences,
非常感谢大家今天的时间。谢谢你们的收听。感谢大家的聆听。我将于下周带着另一期节目回归。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人 Kear Games 主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，
having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. how many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
进行那些在任何地方都不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士一起交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在 iHeart 广播应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian. My mind was blown.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一个恶作剧。艾伦女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安。我的脑子炸了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs. when there is also an escalator available.
我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着季度的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这是走楼梯的人的比例。当同时也有自动扶梯可用时。
I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
我是迈克尔·伊斯顿。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了精神顽强、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. They take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target.
收听《2%》。即 TWO%。在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时。她们开始自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的。我们总是这么说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个 iHeart 播客。
Guaranteed human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证真人。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。